das bild der heiligen familie stammt wen
wundert's aus der bibel
hier wird es das erste mal beschrieben
und sie gingen islands und fanden maria
und josef dazu das kind in der krippe
liegen nur am rande wird in den
evangelien das beschrieben was
jahrhunderte später zum bild der
heiligen familie wird die
religionswissenschaftlerin natalie fritz
hat diese entwicklung analysiert
maria ist quasi die einzige frau die dem
ganzen heilsgeschehen wo irgend relevant
tiroler die einzige bringt jesus
die ersten motive der heiligen familie
konzentrieren sich auf mutter und kind
josef ist zwar da spielt aber kaum eine
rolle
erst die außer biblischen texte und
interpretationen erschaffen bildhafter
erzählungen eines gemeinsamen
familienlebens maria bleibt zwar die
heilige mutter doch sie setzt sich mit
josef an den tisch mit alltagsszenen
wird die religion und das volk gebracht
als die reformatoren die kirchliche
macht ergreifen
ist ihnen die allgegenwärtige
marienverehrung ein dorn im auge wie der
glaube für die pflicht würde
das hat der reformatoren mit post und
sie hat mir ja quasi druckstufe und die
führen sie amüsierte josef stufe wo
vorher eigentlich einfach die nerven als
er die figur geht als maria und es sind
das kann hand aber der schmidt-wyk ihren
vater vor dem kind
aus der nebenfigur josef wird der
vorsteher der familie und es entsteht
das bild der heiligen familie wie wir es
heute kennen von der shampoo werbung bis
zum tv spot wie reif an dem ideal der
heiligen familie nach und immer wieder
hat josef das sagen es ist vor allem der
hollywoodfilm gerne auf das konzept der
heiligen familie zurück greift wie das
beispiel terminator zeigt die heldin des
films wird nach der urmutter des
christentums benannt sarah die frau von
abraham
mehr noch ihr wird ein sohn verkündet
der dieselben initialen trägt wie jesus
christus
er hat uns vor dem abgrund gerettet sein
name ist john connor ihr sohn geboren
und der böse terminator verwandelt sich
später in einen josef der den
zukünftigen messias beschützen soll
du bist nicht meine mission ist dich zu
beschützen was spannend ist dass die
heilige familie in dem schon dem science
fiction sogenannte fokussiert dass die
retter ganz relevant ist wie die heilige
familie das ist quasi keine zahlen für
die zukunft also in der familie der
familie selber schaffe mir die zukunft
team das mich hinterhand und sogar in
filmen die mit dem konzept der
klassischen verbrechen wie bei pedro
almodóvar orientiert man sich an der
heiligen familie
auch wenn maria nicht immer eine frau
sein muss traditionelle familie und das
ideal aber nicht als labors vorbild
josef maria und das jesuskind eine
ideale geschichte die sich immer wieder
erzählen und neu interpretieren lässt